nevada the state's kova task force hopes
more information will be available about
that vaccine in the next month
even so distribution for the general
public will not be
anytime soon but as we wait for a
vaccine the state is doing what they can
to control it
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
joining us live with an update on the
vaccine
right on today's colvin 19 call the
discussion was of the increase of cases
and community spread state of nevada
kovi 19 response
director caleb cage says for the most
recent seven day period
cases are growing at a rate of 1.2
percent
as of monday 10 counties have been
flagged for elevated transmission
including clark the state has completed
a total of one million three hundred and
forty four thousand
three hundred and eight molecular tests
since the beginning of covet 19.
the last 14 days test positivity rate
has been 13.6 percent
nevada continues to see a resurgence and
a significant resurgence in kovan 19
hospitalizations the general consensus
from contact tracing is that they are
we are experiencing community-wide
spread at this time and that there is no
specific
source of that anytime we do have
increased human human contact
caleb says they are pushing local
governments to implement
more enforcement and mitigation measures
if they have elevated cases within the
area
that includes focusing on
contact tracing enforcement as well as
measures like we saw from washoe county
recently
i believe it was two weeks ago going
into effect last week
their reduction from 250 people at
gatherings to
50 people and something to keep in mind
as the holidays are approaching
limiting those large gatherings if you
have the ability to
postpone events cancel events or make
events
smaller that's absolutely an option you
should consider
also on the call the director of nevada
department of veterans services kat
miller miller says that this veterans
day they're going to be celebrating a
little bit differently they're going to
be preparing a video to share so
they make sure that covet 19 isn't being
spread
reporting live near the strip sally
jaramillo 8 news now